you didn't you didn't snitch you took
the time no no they offered me a deal
they came back like multiple times like
I was in the county jail locked up you
know in solitary and they just send
dudes down every week like hey did you
change your mind you change your mind
there's still time like all the way up
to the date of my sentencing and did
they know exactly who they were going
for they knew your connect they knew
everything no no no they knew almost
nothing okay that's why okay so that's
the reason if they if they come and
arrest you yeah and say nothing you're
[__] when they just say come with me
we've got a warrant out like you're done
yeah it means they already have an
indictment they have you on a wire they
don't need anything from you exactly but
when when I got the day I got arrested
they spent hours interrogating me that
means they don't it's like poker when
you have a good hand you're quiet and
when you're bluffing you're blustery and
Loud incorrect so so criminals forget
that too right it's like they stumble
over themselves trying to talk their way
out of it if they keep asking you
questions it means they've got a nugget
but yeah yeah like they're trying to get
you to spill the beans so I just clammed
up you know you had enough separation
between you and the cartels and the
mafia well here's the thing I wasn't
working for the cartels that was just
the Ria that was just the connect okay
let them know so I don't work for you
I don't know that worked for me
[Laughter]
that's crazy
are they not Mexicans but they are it's
a Mexican cartel yeah the way you said
it just felt good that was [__] up at
Home Depot bro that was crazy like
there's other places you can meet them
at well that's how I met them that's how
I met them
[Laughter]
so no no they tried to get me to work
for him at one point though oh really
yeah so I oh
so I would go to them and I'd say okay
give me like 50 joints give me 50 pounds
right and they saw I was moving it so
quick so they would be like why don't I
give you 50 more you know pay you come
back yeah you pay me when you want to
give you on consignment exactly and I'm
like no no no I'm not taking [__] from
you because there's no way when you're
in their debt if something [__] up it's
like now I owe you 150 racks okay hold
on I got a question about that will they
ever give you [__] have someone rob
their own [__] from you so you're now in
debt to them no no way no way they're
super logical dude Mexicans believe it
or not
just like just like me and you
[Laughter]
I mean in Mexico if they want you to
smuggle some [__] they might kidnap a
family member and be like you have to
mule this across right uh but no on the
state side no no it's all it's all just
it's all business okay I want to get to
the beginning of the story but first
this is the number one question I'm sure
you're asked it's the one that
everybody's thinking at home you're
locked up yep you're a pretty little
white boy yeah yeah so I never felt
prettier that ever felt prettier it's a
Tall Tree to climb yeah you know yeah
we'll take two or three of them you know
you know what did it no nothing
unfortunately because because if it had
I have a [__] Netflix
stop dude wait a minute I regret it okay
so but you're locked up in Oregon yeah
okay yeah and there's at no point did
they is there any no no because as soon
as I hit the the main line in the county
jail they were watching old school and
getting tempted by the real life version
sitting right there in the cell no
because I faded immediately like
immediate stand-up fade is a fight you
know so it's like they test you right
away like you can't even live on the
main line which is the the like general
population yeah you have to fight right
away translate everything okay so if you
refused as soon as you like get to
County Jail yeah put your things down
you don't even get a chance to eat you
just walk out and empty stomachs exactly
yeah and you're in like sand you're in
these plastic sandwiches already that
this was going to go down like somebody
told you yes they warned me the dudes on
the Chain as I was getting LED in they
were they were like this is what time it
is you know like to their credit they
were nice they primed me so it was this
big [__] skinhead dude he had just
got locked up a white wanted to fight
you a white yeah oh it's white on white
this way it's rarely Portland bro
plenty of blacks plenty of blacks in the
county jail
it might be Progressive to say too many
yeah I mean like it's actually we got to
stop yeah yeah there are too many
putting all these blacks in prison bro
exactly dude
was that the 14th Amendment what is it
yeah 14th 13th yeah 13th 13th Amendment
yeah yeah we gotta identify the prison
system we gotta move some more white
people in there oh yeah it's the only
place that's diverse in Portland
okay so this big white [__]
comes steps to you yeah yeah and he's uh
and his name is Cameron and he's got
like the swastika right there and you
know it's meth and all that [__] so uh
so he walks up and he [__] I think I
got like my paperwork like I'm sitting
at a little desk in the day room and I'm
just [__] making notes and [__] like
looking at what they're charging me with
like holy [__] I'm [__] and he just
[__] pushes it off the table and he's
like Punk check you know and everybody
it's like being in the lunchroom and
somebody took your milk in high school
and dumped it all over your sandwich you
know what I mean so everybody's looking
they're like you better go dog so we
just [__] found a little blind spot
in the bathroom and I wrapped my
knuckles with like toilet paper right
because I didn't know I don't know how
to fight you know but I knew I just had
to [__] drop them and hit him as hard
as I could
from the jump it was the only way I was
gonna have a chance so we went in there
and we just [__] faded for like a
minute how small is the space smaller
than this studio it's about the the
bathroom's about this size and then you
just you just there's a little corner
with no cameras and you just duke it out
just one-on-one like a fair fight yeah I
caught him and you said the guard
basically caught me four or five times
okay yeah
absolutely too but there was some
respect that you actually fought back oh
absolutely yeah it's not necessarily
about winning but it's about showing
you're not [__] exactly exactly not
worth the trouble too in this video you
said it was over cinnamon roll that was
that was a different okay that was going
to the next jail okay you know so it's
like by the time I actually ended up
getting locked up like going to prison
I'd been in like four or five fights
my security level was like the highest
you could be so next thing you know I'm
in a Maximum Security Prison with
killers
and I'm in there over a weed beef yeah
you know but it's like what was I
supposed to do I had to fight but that's
what kicked my my security clearance how
many different prison systems were you
in so including a jail so you hit like
the holding tank when you when you first
get arrested yeah then you're in uh what
would be the equivalent of like the the
Detention Center downtown Manhattan yeah
and then when you find out you're not
getting out you're not bailing out
you're not taking the deal so they're
not kicking you out yeah that's when you
get sent to like what would be Rikers
which is long-term County jail holding
it right so I'm I'm at the Portland
equivalent of Rikers okay and I was in
there for like eight months and you know
fighting my case fighting inmates yeah
all that [__] yeah yeah
some video where you said I didn't see
sunlight for eight months I'm like bro
you're from Portland
for you you were built for this dog oh
my goodness you did a light eight months
yeah I did 28.8 days though but yeah
28 days
this is the prison outfit they wear yeah
yeah would you get locked up we're just
just being black yes
what the [__] caught the fade over the
Swedish meatballs and [__] you know what
what do you get locked up for what is
Swedish jail like it sounds it's like
summer kids sounds like I said it's so
nice
room Ikea furniture
yeah that actually amazing I had this
thought as I was listening to your stuff
jail sounds so awful because you're like
cool you're a smart dude in your life
but you're like yo selling drugs is a
thing you can do and make money at but
the deterrent is I would get killed in
jail immediately if you're in Europe
where Jail's not that bad there's not
really that deterrent like it's almost
kind of good jail is as rough as it is
in America yes
that's why that's why Europe is like the
co-capital right now that's why
everybody like the cartels make way more
money in Europe yeah you know if you get
your bricks like uh like a brick
wholesale at the border right now
you know in the in America is like 18
Grand over there it's like 60. you know
in Australia it's like a hundreds
wholesale Coke out there they love Coke
why can't they make it in like Cambodia
or something like that is the climate
not right I don't know because they make
heroin down there yeah tons of heroin
tons of meth I don't know they're
figuring it out though yeah they
probably will but it's like it's wild
man they got the best and brightest on
it you know
the r d those Asians will figure it out
yeah so you get so you go through like
all these different systems and everyone
you got to be thinking they're gonna try
to butt [__] me or is that just the
regular person's fear because my fear
about jails the butt [__] I saw some
locked up [__] where the dude was like
the booty Bandit and he was talking I'm
sure everybody's seen that yeah but he
was just going around he was butt
[__] people so that's like my
deterrent like that's the reason why I I
obey the law for real because it's my
fear of Buffalo it's not until you go to
a prison like the long-term sentences
but if you're in jail most of these
people are getting out within a year or
two that's the worst they not because
they're doing it for the Love of the
Game
on the neck like it's exactly that's
tough so maybe that's we can almost
respect yeah yeah he's not doing it for
cup of noodles he's not doing it for
cigarettes
this premise almost got him in a fight
in the Village Lantern like years ago I
know if you remember he said the only
reason I don't want to go to jail is the
butt [__] otherwise I'm stealing
everything yeah some guy got super
offended oh that he was started talking
[__] and then yeah Andrew was about to
go fight him upstairs and then literally
his dad walked up and was like what are
you doing what's going on
a marine
now there was a prison dude
he called Dad he's like yo dad I got a
guy he's waiting for me
no but is that a thing that like prison
dudes are sensitive because the second
I'm watching your [__] and I'm like yo
two years if you didn't choose up as
part of a gang you know no but I mean
also I was Miceli uh Jimmy was a shock
collar for the Hell's Angels in there so
I really lucked out so you know did he
look after you left yes he was my cell
mate and they put me in there obviously
because like I'm the square as one
they're gonna put with the the roughest
dude to try to like deter you know they
try to keep everybody separate you know
so he was a big reason I probably didn't
get killed I was worried about the
sticking bro
so I was just butt [__] was the last
thing I was worried about I swear to
[__] God I swear to god dude 90 of
the gay [__] that goes on in there is is
consensual bro consensual and then they
come out and they're like I was raped or
whatever the same these women in
Hollywood
[Laughter]
six months to the gate that meant if you
quit doing gay [__] like me and you were
straight we've been in there maybe 20
years or so you know we're uh we're
getting sweet we're [__] sucking
whatever it is if we quit doing it six
months before we get out it's not gay
you're good you're going to your life
it's hilarious
that's like written into the [__]
rule book dude
what's
could be like we gotta hurry up dog
[Music]
Behavior
remember he did three years so you had
two and a half years old and trust me if
I could have seen this like whoa Society
we were coming into like at least the
[__] tongue kiss yeah like we would
have been in on it of course it would
have been like buying an Apple stock in
like that I mean like I couldn't see
what was coming dude I thought like I'm
like from that era where like being
straight was like you were like proud
you're like I never sucked a dick you
know and now it's like you can't even
say that take that part out no wow but
[Laughter]
um okay so you went out unscathed yes I
went out on the scale I mean no no but
not like no there was like traumatic
[__] bro you can't call that [__]
unscathed but just just unscathed in the
ass yeah you know yeah okay who's the
scariest person that you saw in jail
yeah I mean like dude I would see I'd be
in the [__] prison shower and I'd see
like some some life or black dude with
like a tattoo tear and like an
abnormally small penis and I'd be like
that [__] will kill you you know
what I mean like that's I would see a
dude like that I'm like that's probably
gonna be in here you know it was like it
was [__] like that it was dude you
wouldn't expect or like you know the guy
that had killed his wife like the
professor you know the genius that uh
had murdered his wife with poison you
know what I mean like weird dudes like
that like that those were the scariest
[__] because they had nothing
to lose right and they weren't like
gang-banging criminals like gang banging
Killers killers that have killed over
drugs or respect yeah it's kind of all
in the game yeah you know what you're
getting into killing your wife with
poison
what
what you're like a year and a half just
a year and a half yeah
no but that is a good point those are
the scariest [__] if you were
to go shoot somebody for some get back
that's different yeah than like just
being an absolute Bonafide psycho
psychopath yeah so you're in there with
Psychopaths so at any point in time they
could snap yeah well bro the first night
locked up with Jimmy I know he's doing
life life Hell's Angels
bro I'm I'm sitting there with my pen
like a pen that's all I had and I'm
sleeping I'm not sleeping I'm sitting
here I'm on the bottom bunk he's on the
top bunk the whole night I'm just
sitting there with the pen cap off she's
like this [__] rushes me I'm
gonna try to hit him in the artery or
some [__] like that you know like didn't
know because he didn't talk to me I
didn't know if he was going to snap and
[__] come down and try to kill me
yeah when do you ingratiate yourself to
him the next day and the next day he was
like I could see you're a good kid and
he gave me a shank he gave me a burner
yeah and he was like I wouldn't leave
unless you go off to like work or off to
you know do something
away from other inmates I would at least
have this [__] on you and when you are
when you're like meeting these dudes
yeah is there like a method to you
becoming their friends are you like are
you feeling energy are you trying to
make them laugh are you just giving them
their space letting them reach out to
you yeah yeah that for sure what is the
anger for sure so because you can't just
go talk to like a dude doing 20 30 life
you can't as like a you're like a
freshman trying to talk to a super city
did anything I think you were uh you
were a chomo no because you just they
knew they know your paperwork that's a
child molester no no brother if you're a
tall white dude they just assumed
they're like oh yeah I would assume that
yeah I'm [__] [__] both of you
[Laughter]
dude because I'm always when I was a kid
I was afraid I was gonna get diddled so
I'm always on the lookout oh yeah but he
didn't ring any bells so you're good
yeah yeah no so they they know as soon
as yeah
himself a one-term really blend in I
know
the one term that's the wrong one
criminals so me and my you know felon
friend can ingratiate ourselves together
you know okay okay I'm commiserating you
know that thing I said about not getting
raped in prison I don't know dude
did you have to get down with like the
white power dudes just for safety no I
refused I refused so that's why like uh
I'm like no I swear to God because it's
like they were like cats they were like
we don't want you playing basketball
with the blacks we don't watch playing
dominoes I'm like well how would you
like me to associate with them though
like what else do you want me to do oh
and you played ball in that yeah so I
had a good a good paperwork I had a good
crime and I was a good Hooper so like
that's what like you know that's how I
got my respect yeah you know so wait but
they let you play ball yeah bro they
insisted on it my first day and locked
up I was walking around the yard I
talked about this in the show and the
black dudes are running it's good
running there too at OSP or no this was
at two rivers and uh and they were they
saw the height and they were like get
over here yeah [__] but I mean
though the white power guys they didn't
mind I mean I think I honestly think it
was it was a combination of Jimmy Miceli
yeah and and the black dudes because
they wanted me to run dude they wanted
me to move is is are the Hell's Angels
separate from white power uh it's white
power is just a blanket term for white
gangs so gotcha there's like the Aryan
Brotherhood that's the big one like
California prisons that's a [__]
gangster if I was in a California prison
I probably would have had to like you
know you have to right would it would
have to put in work or like go to
protective custody or yeah it would have
been bad and if you go to protective
custody you basically end with the choma
you're in with the chomos you're in with
the snitches so you could argue that
might even be worse because now you're
just fraternizing with child molesters
all day absolutely absolutely and then
you and then somebody somebody gets to
you in general population and they say
you've got to kill one of these
[__] or next time exactly
exactly the stress yeah so it's
stressful it's fine but you are killing
a child molester right like yeah but
then you gotta get you gotta go do life
yeah you know yeah okay so they're not
doing that so the thing I'm curious
about is like do you think that you
handle the stress better because you
handled stress outside with the drug
dealing so in other words you think like
your cortisol levels are operating at a
much lower level
or you just become acclimated to being
in a stressful environment it took about
a year it takes about a year to get
acclimated in jail to be like okay this
is what this is where I'm at this is my
home you know you look around it was
honestly the hair loss you look around
all these bald [__] just
stressed out and I was like that's
that's what's going to make me coffee
you couldn't get the protection
in the [__] prison bro I should start
I should have smuggled in balloons
hundred percent of the [__] hair
pills yeah are you on it now yeah you
got it yeah yeah you too right cool I've
been always since I'm 24 years old yeah
you know what it is
it like you combed over but like this
right here
I got a Jewish doctor in the valley
though we're going to get like the
hairline's coming down yeah the next
time I'm on here I'm gonna look like a
Mexican guy
at the eyebrows and go back listen you
got to do the um the turkey I was about
to say turkey but I don't know if that's
like obviously with what happened in
Turkey yeah I'm not going to Turkey
that's I heard turkey they're like the
kingpins of the hair yeah hair is just
Immaculate that's like Columbia for like
3 000. you could do Columbia too
Colombia Colombia is uh turkey is the
hair transplant so Colombia is to tits
so they [__] set up I was going to
invest in a business down there back
when I was balling this guy who I met
there was like I'm setting up this
company where we recruit you know chicks
in the states who don't have them down
exactly a whole pack nice hotel yeah and
back yep they do that with turkey it's
unreal yeah yeah
work with you because you have all your
hair up here exactly yeah we just got to
bring it down like a centimeter
you've got some money stashed yeah I got
money I got my money stashed oh from
that no no not anymore not anymore no